good morning Millennials
good morning millennia hi guys welcome
to the toast I was about to say the B
word the B word but I did good for you
it is such a beautiful Thursday morning
we are 4/5 done with the week honestly
this is like the most Monday Thursday
like I don't even feel like it's
Thursday so I'm feeling really great
folks like to be alive yeah and then
yesterday I really wasn't no and
tomorrow is going to be Friday and then
like our first full week of the toast
haven't immense success yes that huge
big success huge we have so many
fabulous stories for you of course
chose cloudy and ivory in watch
repertoire what happens like I feel like
there's I could write a thesis paper on
what happened a bunch of them there's so
much to unpack there's so much to unpack
and I just feel like I'm gonna get
serious about it and just talk about
like how what happened on TV last night
it's just like in epic moment and like
an iconic moment for our culture and our
generation yeah and it's just proof what
Andy has built some people could say
whatever they want about Andy
but like all you need to do is watch
that episode of watch happens live to
understand how important and how big
what Andy is created at Bravo is and the
cultural impact of it all buddy I'm not
gonna lie it's a little overwhelming
these watch what happens live in LA so
it's like first of all I as you guys
know don't have cable right now not to
make this about me but I record every
episode of watch what happened so I said
always been able to watch him at my
leisure I'm like right now I can it's
the only week that matters so I just
feel like he couldn't have chosen to
work a worst week for me and for me
having to watch it live on my iPad it's
just very stressful and they wouldn't
wish it on anyone but without further
ado let's get right into the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite of your morning
toast I could really go for some morning
toast right now breakfast once this week
I've been just bringing chuchi strings
with me the morning cheese drink yeah I
look like she's stirring at home
speaking pull she strings me but into
them like a savage
Claudia you shouldn't you know the
answer to this question that I'm not a
savage and I would never do that um
speaking of the morning toast it's so
exciting because we got the Instagram
handle oh my god I don't know if you
guys noticed but we went from the
morning toast show to the morning toast
and you know some people just like get
it given to them yeah you can be lucky
enough to like come up with an amazing
name for a Peabody award-winning morning
show and then go to Instagram and the
username is not available which is
exactly what happened to us but then we
reach out to the owner of the morning
toast she was extremely gracious we made
a deal we made like Shark Tank and made
a deal would have an ID on her okay and
I was like hey
she was like okay how much and I said
$50 and she was like no she was hard
balling me I'm like okay her name is
Polly okay
do you use make up Polly no oh you're
just gonna out this girl so okay anyway
you guys could go follow her because I
was like 100 and I don't think English
was her first language so I I thought
like I was gonna get so far with her and
then like it wasn't gonna work out and I
was like 100 she then she agreed so I
did it so I gave her $50 on PayPal
because on paper you're playing paint
your mic is floppy people can't hear you
sorry and with your hair
no is that better it should be sorry
keep your native first shirt but you
just got to keep your hair back I know
but like maybe trying out your chins
maybe trying up to like 100 Chin's and I
could never do that
okay would you rather have 100 Chin's or
no audio no audio base the other way
okay sorry
yeah let's just take them out money
can't buy you class money can buy
[Applause]
this is countess LuAnn new money can't
buy you class I feel like I just sounded
really good maybe that's the perfect
song is this better from my tone yes
that let me know let me know how this
audio is checking out hell again to
learn my friend check one two
we're we good okay okay anyways let's
get started first take a bite out of you
wait so I had any the girl hunt dollars
she was still lovely it worked out well
a hundred dollars is honestly a small
price to pay for branding cheap at the
price
what's the most you would have paid well
when I said $50 you were like that's so
little I'm like no it's not this user
may means nothing to this girl like
she's 90 followers like it's brand new I
was like 10 posts and so then I thought
it was even crazy to do 100 I think you
were telling me like I could go upwards
of 500 Mike [ __ ] are you kidding well
what's it worth to you I'm currently
unemployed true but what's it worth to
you
you're not investing your it was worth I
would have went up like 300 okay
little does she know she's watching now
like when I co-hosted I wake up with
Taylor when she was on Sirius XM I
co-hosted with Clay Aiken and he had
this whole saga that he was like late
Instagram so like some kid took his
username Clay Aiken and he couldn't get
so he was Clay Aiken 13 and he would DM
this kid like on the Reg like just
making nice just in case like he wanted
to ask for her back but then Instagram
like stepped in because he's like an
actual celebrity and he's like running
for Congress so like he has the right to
his name and they took it without like
telling the kid and the kid but I'm like
social media tirade against Clay Aiken
like he changes BIOS with Clay Aiken
stole my username that's crazy that's
like we were saying someone from school
is God like a serum that they just like
they take it without permission which
like if I was clay can I be happy about
but ya know someone they had to step in
because people are making money maybe
now Mark Zuckerberg will stop doing that
because like he's not interfering
anymore he's an alien do you see him
drinking water yes I did he was
spongebob good morning humans okay first
story of the day follow up to yesterday
Tristan Thompson was booed during his
first game since the allegations are not
allegations if there's multiple videos
that he cheated on pregnant OE why do
they have to say allegations but it's
obviously true right it's like no one's
gonna sue you because you could just
show a video right and it's not like
it's obviously it's not hearsay because
right there's put its up supposed but by
the way he was with multiple partners
yeah if you guys didn't much watch on up
inside last night or you've never
watched an episode of Real Housewives of
Orange County that would probably mean
nothing to you anyways the story goes
Tristan Thompson returned to work one
day after allegations he cheated on
pregnant girlfriend Carla shame where he
walked into an a corporate office
building and they went to the one who
sadly sadly made his morning dump and
then watch the morning shows like words
her office like it went to work he went
to Madison Square Garden no he went to
the Cleveland Cavaliers Stadium whatever
so much also I need to talk about
Cleveland right now because Chloe's in
Cleveland and then I was like oh my gosh
they're obviously getting her ass out of
there she can't fly she can't fly and
it's someone mapped it out it's over a
day of a road trip from Cleveland till
she's back around LA you think she just
totally got a like a mobile office
memorandum oh but like Wi-Fi a lazy boy
recliner Irish probably Rodimus ooh
honestly she probably got a fine car
like they exist
people are making them and then she
doesn't have to like deal with altitude
she probably got a fine car and the us
it looked like a UFO saying good morning
me Daniel I just wanted to just quickly
go back to me you said flying carts
don't exist yes they do
people are making them but like not for
commercial use but for Kardashian use
for Kardashian emergency use or maybe
she took a helicopter I don't I don't
know they say you can't fly private cuz
like I mean they say you can't fly when
you're pregnant peace I could go into
labor they're like okay so let's say she
goes into labor it's her plate and she
could land it when she wants that's what
I wasn't cool July I think it might have
to do with the altitude okay force you
like I think there's but that rule just
like might not apply when you're a
Kardashian do you know what I mean yeah
like you're immune to the altitude I
don't know but maybe she did think maybe
she is in Cleveland is everything okay
over there
you know I want to watch on Facebook I
wanted to get some people's commentary
YouTube wasn't as wet as it was
yesterday
oh well Facebook is always like yes
that's where toasters are okay so look
this is actually helpful then Harvey see
you're not supposed to fly but you're
also really not supposed to drive far
either why I don't know even in like a
limousine or like a sprinter a mobile
office a sprinter that's what they're
kind of a sprinter when we you guys won
here the most amazing story what women
into the Super Bowl oh yeah
the greatest weekend of our life we went
to the Super Bowl we were on the plane
and let me got an email from TMZ and
they said that they wanted to speak to
us at the airport like paparazzi and
give me guys how this story we might
have but whatever that's such a sad
story we should tell it again so we were
on the plane like freaking out like I've
never been paparazzi and like I just
wanted to be so like the fact that
someone was noticing was really like
humbling so we landed in Minneapolis we
went to the bathroom and like did our
makeup we looked fabulous I mean had
ordered a car but we're like if TMZ is
watching us like you can't just leave in
a Toyota Camry right so and then we were
like you know it's on the business let's
hook it up so we called but everyone in
town was trying to get like a suburban
like a big black car because all the
celebs were in town so I would called
literally a hundred car service says
none of them answered what none of them
had black cars one of them had an SUV
they're like it might be a sprinter man
it might be a limousine we're like okay
I could be seen getting into a limousine
okay we land in Minneapolis even though
limousines are like beyond it matters
yeah and thinking of the Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills still take them no but
it's like I think it's a parrot I think
it's in their contract that they have to
because it's like Beverly Hills she she
she yeah yeah yeah
so we land TMZ is literally nowhere to
be found
yeah we get our car it's the biggest
Sprinter van ever it literally was
Scott's mobile van it was amazing it was
red our legs and we were like just like
teams are you sure you're not here I
think I hear the the shudders of a
camera
no no just Airport jargon okay just
dreams being crushed literally it'll
happen
don't worry yeah but I thought you were
just gonna talk about the rest of the
weekend which was really fun and I don't
know oh wait nevermind yeah we were
talking about mobile spider-man right
and they say you're just gonna say we
got a certain room and I forgot about
the sad part her first story Tristan
Thompson was booed obviously I read a
report this morning but I haven't
confirmed it that his leg is broken I'm
pretty sure that's take news coming on
in our group last night I'm like this
sounds fake let me google it I forget
Twitter and I think she went to the
hospital on March 4th for a broken hurt
leg and I think it's old fake news and I
don't want to be someone who's
perpetrating it I mean know if they let
him play last night also it's even a
good player ya know when I started
googling Tristan Thompson came in like
Tristan Thompson sucks like no points
Thompson out of joy he's like so good
really yeah I think you guys anyone know
he's totally good we're getting the cuts
he cuts he had which is like I don't
know oh I'm sure last night wasn't good
enough for him well apparently he like
was good and then I started doing Chloe
and then everyone like blamed Chloe for
you know oh right that always happens
please the Kardashian curse except that
when she was dating Lamar he want a
championship even though he was on drugs
okay well Libby is here hi Olivia
hi timber okay mmm Tristan Thompson okay
so I've been thinking a lot about this
because like I first didn't think much
of it let me spoke about it on the show
you know I hadn't had a feel and then
the more I think about it the more
research I do the more like comments I
read on Twitter like I'm almost 100%
certain and then this was some sort of
orchestrated ordeal because it makes no
sense
how so elaborate like the timing is so
bizarre and like the fact that this
video from October was released like if
any news outlet had this video there's
no reason they wouldn't release it
unless there was some sort of Kris
Jenner involvement
yeah I'm just more I think about the
more calculated it seems to me and the
more I don't know bizarre the whole
thing
I don't know I'm most two minds because
on the one hand it's like yes the
Kardashians orchestrate everything down
to the time with AP and everything is
this one right big orchestral master
Taylor Swift that's what they say and
then I'm on of the other mine
where it's like they just keep stepping
in [ __ ] and like things like their whole
brand and everything I think a lot of it
has been just like corns and luck and
coincidence and like they're just so
like everyone is just so enamored with
them that we can't ever stop talking
about that like Kim's robbery was out of
control and same but like that they
didn't plan that member rob ruiz
obviously not planned no but like people
were saying like would be insurance for
what people are saying when Kylie's
pregnant is gonna come out this way it's
gonna come out that way and like no and
the way that it took up coming out like
broke a million records yeah Gina she
wasn't trying even to do that like I
just feel like sometimes it really is
coincidental and I feel it how did like
that picture that started at all of him
in PhD by the way was PhD Hotel hooking
up with a girl like that was taking on
someone's cell phone like you think Kris
Jenner like send someone to take that
picture get them at the hotel like each
other I'm like the two mindsets I'm of
the mindset Kris Jenner is everywhere
then I'm also have the mindset like is
she really I'm just having the mindset
where that she lets the chips fall where
they may and then goes to lunch with
Faye Resnick you know yeah she's just so
busy like I don't know how she runs the
world is the devil in the angel and also
like is has a relationship with Cori
gamble and as a mother I just think all
this stuff happens to them and then the
way that they manage it is what brings
them back on top yeah you know I just
feel like not everything I don't know
but then I also like have read some
stuff that it's like this was all a
setup but this is such a sensitive time
she's literally giving birth as we speak
probably and no one like even the
Kardashians cannot defy like medical
odds okay can I say something cuz a lot
of the controversy that's also if I hear
the saying again the devil works her
because she was like I'm so over it it
was funny the first time three years ago
this is my my question it's like a lot
of the pack lash they're getting now is
that like the Kardashians are still like
on social media Kylie's promoting
lipsticks and Kim's promoting her app
and people are like she should really
stand in solidarity and they should not
be posting clubs going through so much
it's like what like why is that a thing
first of all no but Tristan Thompson
like ruin their business too
I just I don't agree with that logic at
all and I'm seeing so many people being
like I can't believe there went back to
their normally post no one died like
relax I just don't agree with that logic
what so I completely agree with you and
they're like Chloe we're waiting for
Chloe or Tristan to say something like
they're not going to they're not they
don't owe us [ __ ] this is their lives
that we've ruined by consuming all of it
so [ __ ] off go just give birth in peace
no I can't you don't keep promoting your
[ __ ] subscription-based app okay yeah
I still don't subscribe my followers
gave me their subscription like a while
ago and like their log in and I've had
Kim's app on my phone ever since I never
used it I spend to pay for Kylie's it's
really good
well every once in a while there's like
something that they tease on their
profile that I'm like oh I wish I could
see it maybe and then someone will post
it in the toasters and I'm like I'm so
glad I don't pay for this no honestly
the toasters has saved me so much money
yeah like one of them gave me their Hulu
Plus login and sometimes I like tell us
what people say on like serious shows
this mess yeah okay speaking of nothing
we were just talking about
Bravo renews Vanderpump rules and 19
other shows expands to seven nights a
week
okay I'm gonna rattle off and then
there's something important that I don't
think anyone caught in this article and
okay I'm gonna rattle off the article
they have announced her newest 420 in
their original series in addition the
cable network will expand to seven
nights a week of original programming
beginning in fall of 2018 what's gonna
be on like Saturday Sunday Oh Sunday's a
great night Saturday
I don't know hopefully Jeff Lewis
hopefully and Top Chef the network has
confirmed new season orders for the
following shows Vanderpump rules married
to medicine million dollar listing LA
and don't be tardy
yay flipping out Shahs of Sunset Hey
southern term Savannah a million dollar
listing New York Real Housewives of
Atlanta
yeah Beverly Hills yay Orange County and
New Jersey
yay Dallas yeah these series join the
recently premiered original scripted
series imposters and unscripted hits The
Real Housewives of New York yay southern
charm yay Oh Siri hurt us this is proof
the FBI is always watching what is she
saying she's reading off movies shut
this Oh
movie shut oh my god she's so scary
stabbed aah oh my god she's always
listening who do you think scarier Siri
or Alexa Alexa because Alexa has the
power of Jeff Bezos and Amazon behind
them and that's bigger than Apple and
they bigger than Jim cut yeah okay it's
like Jeff Bezos is number one in the
rich person category
it's he he fluctuate yeah nobody he goes
up and down depending on whether or not
you return your Amazon we're totally but
the guy underneath him I don't know who
he is but he's in oil which is so
lucrative we need to get some oil totem
in my hair do you think if you harvest
it all like every night yeah bring it
bring it out start with like just a
small like bucket yeah and then what you
have to do is like go out to like I
don't know New Jersey or something put
it in the ground and be like look at
what I found
oh yeah I will me my friends none of us
wash our hair I get us all together
we'll put it in a big bag a vessel we'll
head out to the Garden State mimic we've
got a rent-a-car cousin let's not drive
rent a car dig it up then we have to
wait like a few minutes cuz we have to
wait for like the ground because the
grave we dug like it's very deep we have
to wait for the ground to like mold back
together come back taking a road trip to
Six Flags hey guys let's stop I gotta
pee on the side of the road anyone smell
that smells like oil they find it when I
get the shovel in the back of my car
dig dig all over the local news no I
don't know if that's so believable what
you have to do instead of going to Six
Flags be like I'm going to move to the
suburbs like I want to best land in New
Jersey you go back to where you think
rich you start like digging to build
your house no one bigger garden and
you've already bought the pot for the
land so you can own it oh my goodness
millions of dollars here I come Nicolas
Cage left this for me okay wait there's
more shows you know and there's
something in there Real Housewives of
New York I southern charm yay the Real
Housewives of Potomac and as well as new
seasons of below techmount a tree does
the late-night talk show watch what
happens like with Andy Cohen Top Chef
okay what do you have to say okay in
this article which like no one's really
picking up I saw it on Twitter give me
two seconds to find it they have a new
show in development it is called the
untitled San Antonio project it's a
working title I saw that and apparently
it's gonna be a new installment of Real
Housewives the Real Housewives of San
Antonio
the doctor series follows a tight-knit
group of women and their families living
in San Antonio Texas who are affluent
sophisticated US citizens are recently
naturalized citizens of Mexican descent
in their upscale and beautiful gated
communities these women will face a new
set of challenges in adapting to u.s.
culture while working to keep the roots
alive and well so that could be an
installment of Real Housewives of San
Antonio but it could also not be it
could also not be where would you want
to see we all have size franchises I
feel like we need either Palm Beach or
Boca yeah we're bringing back Miami
something Florida based maybe Miami
didn't work and honestly Miami is like
it's it's cool and tough but it's not
that like rich like if you're really
rich and you want to live in Florida you
live in like Palm Beach you live in Boca
you live in Merrill a home I got it they
need real house sighs some are like oh
yeah do people live there it's a
vacation place I thought it was a
country club I don't really know I don't
know either
but I agree on Miami I could go for Palm
Beach I could go for Boca
what about like Chicago oh that would be
good too the Real Housewives of the
Windy City
burn where else I don't know
there are Housewives of New England
you know like realize dates no Rhode
Island is rich as hell like carnies yeah
or like when I was on a trip apparently
there's like these mansions oh yeah we
went there like Safari yeah they're
crazy they were like there's summer
cottages and they were like a huge like
garage filled it backs me up no it's
crazy and like the Vanderbilt homes
that's where we yeah yeah okay
that was cool that was cool anyways I'm
so excited thank you Bravo for serving a
premium content much like us speaking of
Bravo Tinsley Mortimer and the coupon
King are back together
are they I'm so happy oh my god wait and
let's recap Real Housewives in New York
with this he is what Sonja was saying
about Dorinda I mean about about tensley
it was so good I mean like that's got
guys from the level that you don't talk
about on the show unless someone's
filing for chapter 11 bankruptcy you
don't talk about their finances said she
doesn't have a plan you know what but
you know what it just depends on its
that's per franchise like I feel like on
Real Housewives of Atlanta anything is
game like they talk about people's
finances people's relationships they
always go below the belt and that's what
makes the show so like epic real
hustlers in New York maybe the reason
it's kind of been a little boring
recently is because they don't go below
the belt like the craziest thing
they say about someone is like about
their business you know right like no
one's even ever questioned Louie honest
like her finances right and then they're
so questionable and by the way something
I want to touch on that you spoke about
yesterday about Lisa Vanderpump's
finances you were definitely onto
something because she posted a that bit
fun at Instagram and let's download lat
tummy T - and you only do that and I
always think it's really like Erika
Jayne doesn't do that she doesn't need
it I always think it's interesting which
have sides because they're supposed to
be a rich but you're not selling
Instagram t like if you're reg right I
told you there's something fishy there
you're right and they might even be
paying her a lot but is it really like
worth the price of like no and I don't
think this identifiers are converting
their coupon codes like I don't think
they're getting lots of sales for mr.
Vanderpump it's very confusing and very
fishy
what other housewives do there are some
houses i shakes what's it called 310 G
yes we can shakes there are some house
as I said when they do it it's like I'm
happy for them cuz I know that they're
going through like financial turmoil and
this is a great segue what one of we're
not going to see you because I don't
want this girl to get in trouble but a
follower of ours
works for a brand that does like social
media marketing and they pay influencers
to promote their product and they reach
up to the biermann's and they got the
pricing for the biermann's
did you not see this know how much
messages on facebook she's been a crazy
time in the meantime I'll let you know
that Tinsley and Scott clues are back on
they got back together a while since he
was filming the distance was tough on
them he surprised her in New York
several months ago and they picked up
right where they left off I wonder if
she surprised him in Chicago dressed as
a Moroccan princess that was some of the
worst advice ever
and I love Tinsley being so brazen like
I'm not really gonna take advice for me
oh yeah if you want to post on Brielle's
Instagram feed it costs $10,000 that's
also pushed to Twitter she's almost a
million followers market value that's
really high just saying for Kim Biermann
who has a little bit more I don't know
how much she has one post to Instagram
that also pushed to her Facebook and
Twitter page is 20 grand then they do
this which I've never seen before cuz
like you know I am a social media
marketer
they like offer sponsored live but uh
live stream live streams yes thank you
so if you want to be like what this is
yeah it's run into a 25 minute
livestream with your product for 24
hours for Brielle it's 10k for Kim it's
25k that's more than
then oppose yeah that's crazy I guess
they're working harder for the money
yeah but it's like not all of your
followers watch your lives I don't know
if this is what people actually pay them
but this is the rate they start
negotiating at so I'm sure they do it
for like 7k that seems like pretty fair
though like it's a little high for
market value but they're very
influential
they're influential and they're famous
as hell and even though like I wouldn't
necessarily buy a product that they sell
I know about the product now because I'm
obsessed with them and like whatever
they do you bought teeth white yeah
Express smile Atlanta which is
mysteriously disappeared from the
airwaves like something maybe they
somebody couldn't rent the bill anymore
but I did buy it it was very hard to use
and it didn't work
oh sorry well I feel like it sees it
more than once I'm so happily Tinsley's
back with her boyfriend you're so
happily me too
I want them to get engaged and married
they're renting a $30,000 a month duplex
penthouse at the Marmara Park Avenue
Hotel that's dancing that is fancy and
I'm so happy there look I just like want
them to like live happily ever after -
I'm just confused
like I know Cooper haven't had a
housewives wedding in a very long time
um and when we didn't get dating kind of
went yeah oh they didn't Tinsley would
totally get one and she would be an
amazing beautiful but beautiful TV bride
she really would Dorinda and Sonja
talking about like her parents
financials like that was so we're love
is just like a hole that walk was weird
no it was so weird and so like I feel
like especially for Tinsley and like
whatever like world she's in like you
don't talk about money finances yeah but
I am interested like who is paying her
in because like a hotel room like
apartment is so expensive and I mean if
Scott's paying it while they're together
like find each other would eat together
but would he be paying for it when
they're not together I don't think so I
don't think so either but do you think
she's getting like some of it for free
because they're filming at the hotel for
sure so it's just so jealous though yeah
like living in a hotel is the dream like
if I could live anywhere on earth I
would I would choose something we'd tell
each episode that passes I'm like
increasingly more upset about their tag
lines especially Tinsley's it's not a
tag line what is it I mean why would I
cook when I could order a room service
right like okay we get it that you're
living in a hotel you could have done
something so much better but that and
that's not a tag line a tag line it's
must be like a summation of your life so
we are your journey this season
Sonja's is good actually I'm not just a
last name I'm a legacy
yeah but that's like a that would be I'm
Dallas I feel like the good one
Luann's is good at sucking dick ative of
what she's going through this year that
bad I don't Bethenny's e sponsored
sponsored by be strong her charity which
like I love what she did for Puerto Rico
but I just don't like it for a tagline I
like it because it's so much of her
storyline I feel like she's found a way
to like make it very interesting for the
show as abusive like I've got shading
everywhere by telling how much everyone
donated Ramona three grand really I know
what as opposed to everyone else who do
I need at zero to pretend ahead I said
that me well first of all this is the
season of Tiffany they're giving her so
good they're giving her so much airtime
definitely got lip injections but not
too much they're pretty subtle I really
like it no and well I loved her last
season I always stand for her even
though like it would became hard at
times because she wasn't giving that
much but I knew she was capable of so
much more and this season like
everyone's filming with her everyone's
going to lunch with her one-on-one like
who knew her and LuAnn were friends her
and Carole so real I think what my
prediction is that her and Carole's
friendship is very real something's
going on between Carol and Bethenny and
I cannot wait to find yeah because like
why doesn't she know that she's saying i
Bethenny's house and why didn't she
invite her to the American Museum of
Natural History gala and why didn't she
donate to be strong yeah it's very weird
I think that Tinsley because Carol
introduced her to Scott Tinsley is like
going all in on Carol but Carol's like
making a lot of enemies to season
because I don't think Easterns at
Bethany she and LuAnn are like not
getting along LuAnn has got to stop
talking about atom dating her niece like
it never happened
relax but IRA nice had a crush on him I
see Tinsley and Carol kind of becoming
like a twosome and like isolating
themselves but that's what how does
games yeah I don't like that move well
let's talk about Carol's marathon
because I'm not gonna lie I was
completely uninterested in the storyline
and like in the marathon life I LA and
that's nice in the poppy back what she
had last season in the elections of
friendship I were in the pot like she
wants and in the marathon of life no
it's in the marathon of life it's not in
the marathon of life that's the problem
they're complaining the two Rowhani
taglines they're just not certain what
Kara's age is just a number
age is a mind over matter if you don't
mind doesn't matter
already asleep I love Ramona look
Dorinda I have a little heart I have a
big heart but little patience not enough
not enough age is an issue of mind over
matter if you don't mind
it doesn't matter she could have done
better age is an issue over mind of mind
over matter if you don't mind I don't
matter her tagline is perfect and also
it reminds you that she is old 60 Plus
which is crazy because she's Britney
Spears Kinsley come on
why couldn't I cook when I can order it
room service you can do so much better
that's just not a tagline so yeah I'm
not just a name I'm a legacy perfect
Luanne be strong most interesting people
make them both bets headlines who's
where we're looking for Carole it's not
in here no yeah that forgettable oh my
god Oh Carole oh yeah in the marathon of
life loyalty is everything how do you go
from marathoning to loyal and by the way
if you're really talk about loyalty Adam
totally ran in front of you and finished
like an hour before you we in the
marathon how would you finish out in the
marathon of life like I win the gold
yeah I got always finish first for me in
the marathon of life I always loved
that's me oh my goodness okay
also LuAnn and Sonja going out to lunch
in the freezing cold like wearing
scarves and like hats City Vineyard City
Winery sorry I stopped watching halfway
through oh right yeah they went to lunch
and as an actor sat outside and it's
almost November and they were freezing
like I was thinking like I hate how like
all these real have sighs the first few
episodes are so boring and I think we
know there's meat there so why don't you
just skip to it because you're gonna
lose people no but there's not meat
there because a lot of the franchises
they don't hang out but right which mean
they shouldn't cut out some of this
filler where like they're all just
catching like and we don't need to know
like who kept up with who while you're
not filming like just commence your
co-workers
commence inside you're all teachers you
didn't hang out over summer break yeah
but get your back in the teachers I
totally agree that one great show about
teachers and teachers lounge yeah but
like you couldn't because like you can't
film students no but just the teachers
oh it is this it's called Summer Heights
High oh I've been meaning to watch it
but no I don't know TV
Jaggi it's so good I know I know I'm not
three-time I downloaded HBO GO just to
watch it but every time I go to watch
I'm like oh [ __ ] I need
I texted you chat yeah no everyone but
you may is on there too and so is Jonah
from Tonga
I don't remember back about that one I
don't like Jim let's talk about the
marathon because like as much as I was
so not into the storyline um it was such
a beautiful ending like I literally was
crying and about shirts because I had
two margaritas and like I was a little
drunk or because margarita I would do
barboonia you did I just there last week
and they would be were there last night
Sara so embarrassing they literally made
me wait for a table for 20 minutes
waited like 30 minutes but when they
give us like a little cocktail table at
the front so we like how to drink well
this is what happened I said hi I'm
gonna be two people and she was like oh
okay we'll have a table for you shortly
when your person gets here or you could
sit at that high table I was like great
thanks she Tara took that as an odd
dating - that's annoying and so by the
time Rebecca's out there we're waiting
we're waiting 30 minutes go by and we're
like how long for our table she's like I
thought you guys took that table oh
that's really annoying all of our
waiting didn't even count oh that's so
innocent
that's really [ __ ] in a way yes
whatever so I literally was hysterically
crying when she was just talking about
her like her husband ran it and used to
talk about it all the time like she
never really gave it a listen and like
now that she's been through it she was
she had like been more like
communicative been with him about it and
like I don't know I just feel like to me
like I think the worst thing in the
world that can happen she was like for
your husband to die cuz like I would
like sometimes I think about what
happened like a Ben would die and like I
look like I would have I would commit
suicide like I would kill myself like I
don't want to be alive without that and
like and like she went through that and
like I had to like live life without him
like I just can't imagine anything worse
so like I actually no matter what
happens I always feel really bad for ya
and same with Dorinda yeah
yeah for sure Dorinda talks about it a
little bit less but yeah like Korea she
can't like live in the past and be with
and she stills the house in the
Berkshires challenge she's okay oh yeah
true okay this next story is very random
Thank You Olivia I didn't read the story
it sees me channels tiffany thornton is
pregnant with her third child see her do
you know this woman wait I'll tell you
what she's from in a second when I did
one Disney do you know this woman have
you seen this woman jegi there's one
Disney Channel star who's been through a
lot is this her no isn't that debby ryan
no she was I think it's this girl and I
follow her on Instagram she's very
Catholic and because she's been through
so much her husband died her yeah and
she she said it was a chance her first
husband Christopher Kearney died in a
car crash
Arkansas in 2015 he and Thornton were
married for four years but something
really bad happened to her before that I
think also one of her kids passed away
some now I'd follow her on Instagram
because she's been through so much it
makes me so sad oh my god that something
happened you do follow her on Instagram
yeah well I I read an article about her
when her husband died and then I went to
her Instagram just to see what she
posted about it she posted like
literally the saddest caption like it
was so real I'm telling you like
husband's dying is like my worst
nightmare and I just really liked her
and I felt so bad for I followed her and
Instagram for a little bit um something
else happened to her and then people
were like speculating about how she fell
in love so quickly but I'm so glad she's
pregnant when something happens like
that you have to move on quickly because
if you don't like you will wallow in
self-pity forever yeah people are saying
that her kid is still alive but her best
friend died oh yes that's right
okay sorry not kidding I can't God for a
bag of her bread um she cuz I heard it
was Jackie who's like within a month her
two back-to-back Instagram posts were
like mourning her friend and then her
husband and her husband was so hot
that's terrible yeah I really like I
followed her and stream I was like I
want her to make Instagram money so like
she doesn't have to worry she's been
doing on guys it's all follow tiffany
thornton yeah and how Co oh my god I
love him is amazing oh he was like
[ __ ] crawling all over me and in his
sleep last night he was annoying the
[ __ ] out of me but like cloudy fix your
audio woman I'm sorry I'm so no the
other one I'm sorry as everyone we need
like a buzzer to go off yeah your audios
it's just kind of juggs and the hair and
the physicality of it all it's difficult
being me for sure but like that's why
you're so it's like the best at what you
do well I'm really happy Tiffany
Thornton's pregnant like I really like
weirdly take a liking to her meaty I
don't even remember her being a shocking
justice for sunny with a chance even
though like they got a chance and it was
ruined because it's a terrible show I
just really it wasn't good for Demi
Lovato
mentally err no no she was going through
a lot do you watched her documentary
right yeah
except then I was like I won watched
just others
humanity that she's talking about where
she said she was like hi the whole time
and going into the bathroom member yeah
and it's to do coke they couldn't find
that documentary because it's like I
just want to see what she's like talking
about I was so drunk at this concert
like I want to see what that he didn't
looks like her and if there was any
signs that like we could have seen then
she was yeah now I look at like all like
Hollywood award shows the sons of like
who's [ __ ] up everyone is now that
like I'm an adult who drinks a lot and
like goes to events and like goes to
places drunk like if I was a celebrity
and like it wasn't my first award show I
was like jaded I would drink at all of
them for sure it's like the best party
of the year or if you're at the Grammys
like that's the best concert ever and
that's why I like Taylor Swift because
like she was the only one who was
dancing out all of those functions and
even though she can't dance it's like
that's what a normal girl said we do
every single one of their favorite
artists was on stage playing the hits
yeah the top top 40 yes so like she is
if she could dance it would have been
cute I agree and if she wasn't like
annoying and manipulative that also what
if a kid I don't know like I just got I
really go back and forth mature and I
don't know where I stand this minute but
like I'm okay with her love to point
look I just wish she would make amends
with the Kardashians like I want to
start a GoFundMe for Tiffany Thornton
but like for Instagram followers yeah
and then one for myself too why don't
you just like shout her out on like
repost something like if she ever post a
meme like sorry okay what's our final
story our final story is that Andy Cohen
reveals to the worst watch what happens
live guess was oh he said it at the
Amber Rose yeah well does his article I
don't know it's from April 11th 2017 no
way no he's always said that but he said
it was because like and he always feels
bad but he says it because she didn't
drink right but I don't know why this is
he said that before here's why he knows
that it's a safe answer to say and like
why it doesn't even mean anything he
revealed that Emma guest was Amber Rose
was the one of the worst guests to hear
on his show where did he reveal that um
he told a news he said Amber Rose she
didn't want to answer any of the shady
questions she turned to me she goes am i
horrible guest I go you're in the
running from one of the worst guests
we've ever had so obviously it's like a
joke this isn't shocking to her like she
knew she was about it is not Chucky it's
not a fair answer and I think that he
pleaded the fifth I think he could do
better I agree that's that's an
interesting person because she's so sure
and like it's always putting her [ __ ] on
blast like on Instagram that like why
wouldn't she just answer it because it
was all about the Kardashians and I
think that she does try to like separate
herself from no and I think that she's
smart enough to not make enemies of them
yeah she even posted something like
Chloe but you know what episode like if
I had to think of who and become one
would say is the worst guest I haven't
seen every episode but there was one
episode that gave me a pit and I and I
know and II felt weird about it with
Joel McHale did you ever see that
episode and I don't see I'm vibing at
all and he was doing all of his like
puns and like yeah we have the soup and
the dupe and yeah we can't was like
really like really yeah it was years ago
who watched chill Miguel's new Netflix
show I feel like he loved it I loved the
soup like this soup was everything
together back in the day and then
someone was like the soup is back so I
watched on Netflix in first of all it's
like they just started it and I was like
is anyone are gonna tell us what this is
like then they brought in the Santa
Clarita people drew barrymore that show
has done to be stopped olifant I think
and it's pronounced elephant I was I
wasn't working for me I gave it like
five minutes I was like nope I love
Netflix originals but like I'm having a
hard time with like Netflix original
like daytime like Chelsea like interview
type Joel mccally I stick to just like
TV scripted shows the soup opened with
just like him talking about American
Idol they called the soup these what
Mike Hales show me um but it's called
the soup like just making fun of
American Idol and it's like one it was
just like such a harsh way to open in -
it wasn't funny yeah maybe if it was
funny don't you think like now that it's
weird that the soup was on a like it's
so not an e program cuz they've really
elevated Brandon but also that other
weird show that like where they made fun
of web shows was on what was great
afterwards do you guys know what I'm
talking about
so he's living Lohan though so but no
that makes sense yeah that was amazing
um I wanted to talk about American Idol
because we haven't spoken about it I
know
and we talked so much [ __ ] about all the
stuff leading up to it every time they
announced a new judge every time they
said it was coming back with your
opinion Katy Perry and we just couldn't
stop talking [ __ ] so when it came time
for the show to come we have to watch
them so much for research purposes and
so we could like have a laugh mm-hmm I
take back everything I said everything
every mean thing I said about Katy Perry
I think she's a wonderful judge I think
she's so funny into you and like
with the times with the kids yeah and
it's like yes she's like tries to be so
like good morning Lenny she's the
definition of good morning Millennials
she would be the host of good morning
millenia yeah but it would be good
you know the premise is bad no each
judge is like really taking shape like
Lionel is like wise and funny and that
gives really good advice heart yeah has
heart Katy is like not really like
interested in people's like talent level
she's just like once so pretty and like
flirt with everyone which I enjoy cuz I
would do the same and Luke Bryan is like
just go so we're just so we're just and
he just brings a little bit of like
coming like and less seriousness then
there are it actually isn't very serious
and no one is really like the Simon but
then sometimes it's like you think
they're just gonna let someone through
because like their story is sad and
their voice is okay but then they don't
and they she that well I really like
lost oh that's a sad story yeah I
thought Noah Davis was gonna win the
whole thing and he like got out in
Hollywood and I mean in a boot camp
round I can't in a shank and like they
never showed Carolyn Craddock singing
and like that is not okay yeah
apparently like this is were so excited
we start we've really watched it because
of her Margo our sister is obsessed like
I have stopped watching pretty much but
she watches every week and she like
deems all the people on Instagram and
like gets really good info apparently
it's like a crazy stage scripted show
like they already know who's gonna win
and then like they have like subsidiary
characters so it like good personalities
and like decent voices that I want to
make it to the top ten and like it
really like it's not predicated base I'm
like how good of a singer you are but
apparently like the ratings are so bad
and I was about like oh hey maybe the
viewership isn't there but if people
watch it they'll like it because it's so
so good and like it defies the odds of
what you thought it was gonna be but I
think I read an article that they might
like canceled at midseason so bad really
yeah but the first episode had ten
million viewers but that's like not yeah
which is crazy like but it's not good
compared to like the boys we need to
bring back x-factor like that it was the
show
but it ain't never did good in the u.s.
we mean with harmony remember people
watched ripped through the waist we fall
into the river
[Music]
hahahaha I know it's gonna be I know
it's gonna be I know it's gonna be I
know it's gonna be I know it's gonna be
I know it's gonna be I know it's gonna
be I know it's gonna be that so good I
felt like I was in pitch perfect 3 but
then again I wasn't terrible so pitch
perfect 3 it's the worst movie I've ever
seen in my whole life in my whole life
like honestly it's tied with the lobster
you know that's actually the worst thing
I've ever seen oh and I think what makes
it worse than the lobster is that it
should have been so good and like it's
so easy to make good it wasn't made for
you like the last it was not made for
you know you can respect why maybe
someone else might like it who's not you
but the pitch for victory was made for
us and it's the worst movie I've ever
seen so unfunny this is the thing you
know what I'm gonna and it wasn't dj
khaled that ruined it it was the own
people who wrote it that room I'm gonna
make him analogy okay hit me
The Godfather is a trilogy technically
but people don't consider the third
movie a part of the trill of the series
because it was was in Francis Ford
Coppola and like it wasn't any of the
same actors it was literally like
someone wanted to make a movie in they
called her The Godfather three great
that's like what happened to thought
that bring it on right so similarly like
the pitch-perfect wanted to were just
epic like two was not as good as one but
it was still pretty good
I don't think third is shimmy I think it
was a movie called pitch perfect 3 I
don't think it was like part of the
church all the same characters no I'm
gonna make a better analogy because one
is always good High School Musical one
fantastic hangover one fantastic 2 is
always a low pitch perfect 2 was not
good I only saw it one time he just like
this was their strategy for picture
perfect to rebel Wilson yeah and I'm
like a little over her no I love her but
it's like they just think that they can
throw her at any problem and like it's
not always gonna work so like High
School Musical 2 terrible at the Country
Club please
oh yeah or two terrible then comes time
for the third they've learned from their
mistakes High School Musical 3 epic epic
it was in theaters that was crazy I was
crazy
hangover 3 epic corrected all of their
mistakes which one was hangover 3
Bangkok no that was hangover - yeah
mister well good hangover 3 was with
well they're all with Leslie Chow but it
was like epic Leslie Chow where was it
that convinced yeah they were back in
Vegas it was it was just so good and so
you would think by pitch perfect 3 like
we're back at that level yeah if this
was like one this was two you would
think three would be here
are you sick let you have a cold one two
three oh a physicality yeah are you sick
typical no why some like do something a
little like look you up a little stuffed
maybe it might be my allergies coming to
fruition because you sound like Phoebe
Buffay wouldn't she get sick like this
please you know I'm not going to do that
I'll literally pay $100 Dan I'll pay you
how much I paid no I'm not that flew it
I can't okay
look at camera do it you're so mean haha
its elder but I'm only doing this
because like someone asked me we're
doing it for ratings we're thirsty now
right we always work yeah that was gonna
be just Harvard maybe that's why
everyone said that the UM disharmony
reprisal was amazing and maybe it's
because like I have nodes
I can hit though the people said be
harmonized I tried to let's do guest on
typically this is my trick with
harmonizing I see do it really softly
just in case it's yeah okay do you want
to do something else let's get strong oh
okay Gaston
that was so good that was good
I'm telling I could hit the low notes
are you waiting you wear that girlfriend
[ __ ] perfect I know you're bringing
snow yeah even oh and you look like her
too thank you okay wait let's do another
one
um what else do we saying do you want to
do some this is me which is greatest
showmen okay greatest showmen or Camp
Rock oh it's always a hard choice okay
are you gonna harmonize our monuments no
you're gonna take the top book or
something I'm not there yet and this is
only like day boy rather thing sec where
you can start from I'm not a stream
that's too slow you got it
look out cuz here come look out Casilla
Rock I'm not scared to be seen I'm big
no I mean you're just saying what I'm
seeing really quiet it's hard okay
forget it
yeah yep we did it we should have quit
we were ahead and now about ok so what's
on TV tonight Jers day thursday southern
charm looks epic Naomi goes in for jay-z
kinda he that he's a con men I know I
can't believe he should be in the show
imposters no but like all these seasons
is like he was like that's what they're
all aspiring to be like a Gentry
business owning restaurant owning
married man with children they were
always like the grandparents like that
what they'll be when they stop drinking
and he's literally I was gonna compare
him to a eugene levy from shits Creek
because he like is fraudulent and loses
all his money but always dress it's nice
thing but no because Eugene has a heart
and he never cheat on Maire yeah Eugene
Levy has a heart yeah I don't know who
he is well I'm watching um I've been
watching Jessica Jones and there's this
conning couple and like he's totally
just a con man so we'll be recapping
southern time tomorrow
that's our Friday we're all so I'm just
letting other women of southern charm
are just like they are like they they
pregame this party and the women pregame
together so it's like Naomi Kathryn
Danni and Chelsea and I just love the
four of them they're drinking wine and
talking [ __ ] and like being so funny it
just elevate them classy and the boy
that's what something charm should be
and the boys are trying to figure out
how to work a smoker and they're just
all fighting and like Craig is being
chef is because she's the men in that
show are women yeah
no but that's like an insult to women
because yeah we like women know when to
admit like that they don't know how to
use a smoker yeah the I don't know what
they're gonna eat us what's it smoking
Oh like they're trying to smoke some
food it's crazy and then they just keep
juxtaposing it and it's like they're so
funny so childish actually an insult eat
children Oh before we wrap we have to
talk about well chop inside from us and
we just watched it oh my goodness it was
so amazing so epic that audience was
literally Jerry Springer vibes like
going if I was in the audience who had
been going it's like when Nene and Reza
start fighting it's crazy but I don't
know there's something about it's like I
love it
I'm here for it it's my dream come true
like I would fantasize met all these
people mingling there's something about
it that's just like a little
overwhelming and like it's like each
because you like talk and we live gets
like five seconds so it's like they're
just trying so hard and I neither lands
or it falls flat
who could you have done without besides
Jenni Pulos the obvious choice right I
don't like her I could have done without
like I wish I had just focused on the
people that actually spoke while they
were there like Adrienne I guess she did
talk about palm no and I was like I I
needed to see her yeah and that face I'm
trying to think then I mean I could have
done without Jeana Keough no she's the
best and I wish they it honed in on the
Vanderpump world's characters and didn't
invite everyone so I can know who was
topped here
yeah I agree because like Billy's didn't
even say anything but I love her but
like she didn't say anything no and like
Kristin didn't say anything yeah
even when she was talking about who need
to Tom Schwartz because we needed to
hear about Rihanna I guess we need a
Gina Kushina and brandy and like them
getting along it's just so weird I'll
never be okay with that no and like them
then fighting on stage around another
guy like I didn't like that didn't mean
it made me feel weird inside oh this I
miss when Bravo did the network like uh
commercials with all these Bravo with
the circus they don't do that anymore it
was so that it was and like that's how
you knew who was topped here because
they only chose like Lisa Vanderpump
Reza like a high top top grade it will
Salas you have top tier
Dorinda got the top villain we were we
were so confused like it was called
Dorinda medley and the night of 31
doorbells and I was like why that is
such a prestigious to be number one I
mean she's on stage the whole time to
have the show named after her and I
couldn't understand why she's three four
seasons
she's definitely good and she's a fan
favorite but she's no og like it was
just weird then I realized why cuz her
last name is medley and it was a medley
of Bravo liberties I don't but then we
said it should have been Dorinda and the
medley of 31 stars or whatever yeah and
then it was like what's the night of a
hundred stars I mean it's a thing it's
like Oh Perry tale I don't know Oprah's
is like [ __ ] you many like too many puns
going on you know Smee and the weirdest
part of the whole thing was Gretchen
you'll find out in a few weeks of them
if I'm pregnant why are you gonna have
sex tonight like it was so weird
no it was so weird and that's what I'm
saying she got five seconds of airtime
so she was like go to my answer and find
out if I'm pregnant in a month yeah like
I could have dealt without her and now
it's bad so weird I was and he was like
her late have been engaged for ten years
oh are you talking about Slade Smiley or
Slade Brielle's boyfriend both new and
she proposed what oh yeah MIT weed hurts
rejecting man she was taking that 100
year old guy with cancer yeah that was
crazy like she could have been the first
Africa Jane she's the og Erica Jane but
instead of like songs she knew handbags
her handbags are so ugly
I would not okay I'm gonna buy one and
wear it around I think that would be
just like a satirical and funny how much
it cost
probably like $75 that's a lot of my pay
if I had a hundred for my username
that's my bar now like and if the shirt
is $50 username was a steal I don't care
it's like this shirt is $50 it's not
worth half my show yeah half my brand oh
my goodness I'm not okay please no one
go check if it's gretchen Rossi is
pregnant in a month like I know I don't
want to hurt her thing to have worked
you know we say you've got five seconds
on watch what happens live what would
you say follow me on instagram i Club
with the shop girl with the job at the
morning shows what would you say okay on
Instagram at Jackie O problems I
probably [ __ ] it up and say a girl was
not a problem
oh for sure well it's been fun it has
been fun
make sure you're following me at the
morning I've always been ending with the
toast every day okay so what do we want
to toast you today to everyone following
us on social media and tiffany thornton
she knew it - Tiffany let's just leave
it right make sure you're following the
morning toast on Instagram at the
morning toast Facebook the morning toast
ever
the morning toast we go live Monday
through Friday chapter six morning
toshow so like what is your judgment so
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time we're recapping jurors
day tomorrow recapping southern term
tomorrow anything you want to see tweet
at us I'm girl with no job tweeted us
let me know what you want to see I'm
Jackie O problems at Tokyo problems are
you sure I don't know find out we will
see you back out in a muggy I don't use
my expertise
[Laughter]
[Music]